These days, movie fans know that the credits
rolling doesn’t always mean the movie is
truly over.
Even before Marvel Studios was using scenes
during and after the credits to tease their
upcoming films, studios and directors were
relying on small scenes to bookend their entire
story, or just offer audiences another laugh.
But some of the best after-credits scenes
hit theaters long before audiences knew to
find them.
Make sure you rank your favourite in the comments
section below!
Here are Screenrant’s 10 Hidden Movie Scenes
You’ve Never Seen.
Pirates of the Caribbean
Disney's swashbuckling series used post-credits
scenes for small gags, including a ghostly
Monkey and a worshipped dog.
But for the third movie, series star Will
Turner made a serious sacrifice, choosing
to take over as captain of Davy Jones’ ship
- which meant setting foot on land just one
day every decade.
Will still got to marry the love of his life,
Elizabeth, but it was the post-credits scene
that delivered the real happy ending.
With the pair's son now ten years old, he
and Elizabeth watch as Will's ship returns
in a flash of green light, with the wayward
sailor set to meet his son for the first time
- teasing an obvious adventure starring the
Turner family, if Disney ever decides to tell
it.
Harry Potter
He may not be what comes to mind when you
picture a magical con man, but the magical
celebrity Gilderoy Lockhart lied, exaggerated,
and charmed his way into the Harry Potter
series.
But his swagger cost him his memory in the
second film, when a spell backfired and wiped
his mind.
A post-credits scene proved his talent for
fame wasn't affected, already out promoting
his new biography, "Who Am I?"
The Grey
The story of a plane load of oil workers forced
to survive in an Alaskan winter wasn't a happy
one - as one by one, the men are picked off
by a pack of grey wolves.
The film ended with Star Liam Neeson strapping
broken glass to his hands and taking on the
pack's alpha, but cutting to black before
audiences could know who came out on top.
The ending fit the endless struggle between
man and nature, but director Joe Carnahan
offered one more hint.
A post-credits scene shows both the wolf and
man wounded and wheezing, and even if fans
can't really tell who won the fight, it's
an even more powerful image to drive home
the movie's message.
The A-Team
The big screen reboot of the classic TV series
wasn't the hit that the studio hoped for,
but that didn't mean members of the original
cast had any hard feelings.
Although their cameo appearances were cut
from the film, the scenes were spliced back
into the movie's end credits.
Fans of the TV series can watch as actor Dirk
Benedict, the original "Face" gives some advice
to Bradley Cooper, and a white coat-wearing
Dwight Schultz finds out just how much crazier
the new version of "Howling Mad" Murdock is
compared to his original performance.
Zombieland
There’s no question that the surprise cameo
from Bill Murray in this zombie killfest is
among the best in years, appearing as himself,
just trying to survive in a zombie apocalypse.
The actor winds up being killed by the stars
of the movie, followed by a memorable final
scene.
But following the film’s credits, audiences
got an added bonus that didn’t make the
cut of the movie.
Rather than using his last breaths for a deadpan
gag, the scene shows Murray reciting one of
his best-known lines from the classic golf
comedy, Caddyshack.
Hancock
Will Smith was anything but your typical superhero
in this action/dramedy, but by the end of
the movie, Hancock had accepted the role of
a superpowered do-gooder.
Of course, he still had a bit of an edge.
Those who stayed through the credits got to
see that for themselves, when an armed hostage
taker decided to disrespect the movie’s
star.
It was a fitting joke to end the movie on,
but comic book fans will appreciate that the
criticized black leather suits of the X-Men
movies made its way into another superhero
story.
Lethal Weapon 3
Post credits scenes are usually used to tease
a sequel these days, but they can also be
used for one last gag.
But no end credits joke is more staggering
than Lethal Weapon 3.
The movie opens with stars Riggs and Murtaugh
trying, and failing to defuse a bomb.
The studio had actually paid for the demolition
of the building so it would be even more convincing
in the movie – and when director Richard
Donner found out the Soreno Hotel nearby was
going to be demolished, he had to take advantage.
The post-credits scene put the partners in
harm’s way one last time, even though that
explosion wasn’t technically their fault.
Baseketball
This sports comedy from the minds behind South
Park has become a cult hit since its release,
but it boasted some truly impressive talent.
Outside of the main cast, famous sports commentators
Bob Costas and Al Michaels showed a sense
of humor, appearing as the go-to play-by-play
men for the movie’s strange baseball/basketball
hybrid league.
But those who sat through to the end credits
were treated to even more of the pair’s
comradery, with a post-credits scene that
shows the two broadcasters working their way
to a passionate kiss, before playing coy to
the camera.
Green Lantern
Post-credits scenes don’t always make a
movie better.
Since DC’s first Green Lantern movie was
less than a hit with fans and critics, most
viewers left the theater as quickly as they
could.
But to make things worse, the post-credits
scene wasn’t meant to deliver a joke, or
even a bit more action.
After Hal Jordan managed to wipe out the movie’s
villain, the bonus scene showed his mentor,
Sinestro, slipping on a yellow ring to master
the power of fear.
In the comics, it was the exact action that
created Hal’s greatest enemy, and the perfect
villain for a Green Lantern movie – and
fans were enraged.
Choosing a silly, big-brained bad guy because
you don’t know any better is one thing.
But when this scene showed the filmmakers
knew Sinestro was the real threat, and were
just saving him for a sequel, fans took it
as the final straw.
Super Mario Bros.
OH YES WE DID!
It might be famously known as the worst video
game movie ever, but the makers of the Mario
Bros. movie definitely had an imagination.
Fans of the video game were disappointed to
realize that the movie had almost nothing
in common with the actual games, but according
to the movie’s fiction, Nintendo is to blame
for the differences.
In a post-credits scene, two Japanese men
are shown talking to the movie’s comedic
relief – Iggy and Spike – about developing
a video game based on their adventures.
Every child of the 1980s saw the movie, but
few may realize that the games are based on
the movie… according to
the writers, anyway.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite after-credits
scenes and stingers?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to get
access to more videos like this one.